keep the st patrick's day festivities
going with some fun with our friends at
the atomic saloon show and joining us to
tell us more is to zan cleary hello how
are you i'm great thank you very much we
are ready to go and you guys have quite
the show at atomic solutions tell us a
little bit about the show it's a little
bit uh it's like the love child of
blazing saddles and a night of the
roxbury
two together that's a perfect
description yes it is a little bit of
dancing a little bit of comedy a little
bit of everything very very sexy amazing
talented acrobats singing cowboys and
world-class comedians now
you've been doing irish dance for a very
long time
since i was three years old
tell us a little bit about i mean do you
have any tips uh and someone
let's i've never done it now give me a
tip okay hands down by your side okay
feet in front okay there you go point
your toe okay and then everything from
your hips up uh-huh stay still okay and
then go for the clappers down below five
six seven eight
there you go
how are you doing there you
oh go i should probably leave it to the
experts
you're much better at this
so atomic salute where is it located and
and what what all happens i mean this is
not just your average irish dancing show
there's a lot going on no it isn't it's
um located at the grand canal shops
between palato and the venetian and it's
on
from fridays to
tuesdays every night 7 30 and 9 30 show
and no it's not your typical irish dance
i play a character called bridal
skunkton
and i didn't bring her along today
because she's quite naughty yes i guess
i know that yes but i did bring along
her brother and paddy because i promised
him that he could do a bit of irish
dancing oh he has two left feet he does
i had to i did promise him the week
that's in it being said patrick's week
how about i step to the side and i let
you two take this stage how does that
work
okay i'm going to move over and i'm
going to let you two kind of show us how
it's done okay all right yeah atomic
saloon
over at it the green canal shops take it
away guys
bring it up there puppy
thanks very much
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
okay
okay
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
oh my gosh atomic saloon
that was incredible you can see the
bodies boosiest brawl and wildlife show
and real life saloon in vegas friday
through tuesday 7 30 p.m and 9 30 at the
venetian
we'll be right back great